las vegas sands releasing its final
results for the third quarter today
properties include the venetian of
course the sands expo here in town
as well as properties in singapore and
macau kirsten joyce joining us now live
in studio with details kirsten
brian ceo sheldon adelson says the las
vegas recovery is well underway
he says weekend occupancy at sands local
properties have been as high as 70
percent
while they say the weekend market is
surging midweek is not
las vegas sands president robert
goldstein says there are still some big
challenges before we can get convention
and large groups to return
the biggest factor they point to is
governor syslak's group and size
restrictions
restrictions and that's typical uh the
airlift's got
mostly people require air lift it's not
it's not driving business so that's
i think that'll come back when the
market
demand is there and the third thing i
think to really fully populate the
market with
group demand again is a change in a
catalyst to change
how the consumer views you know being in
a place with 30 40 50
000 people he adds they get calls every
day
people are itching to come back to vegas
especially convention goers and small
tech groups they hope it will kick back
in
april may june of next year denise